.
THAT FEND WAS ABOUT TO STYLE
HIS WIFE'S HAIR INSIDEHEIR
HOME
>> Jesse: LORI LIGHTFOO IS
NOT ING ANYTHING TO STOP THE
MADNESS.
SHE I TOO BUSY TELLING US WE
CAN TAKE A BITE OUT OF R
MUFFINWITHOUT SPREADING COVID.
DAVID LOPEZ I A CHICAGO CITY
ALDERMAN AND HE JOINS US NOW.
SO RAYMO, S IS BASALLY
WILLING TOACRIFICE THE LIVES
OF HERWNONSTITUENTS.
ST YEAR.
JUST SO S COULD LOOK TOUGH
AGAINST THAT MEAN, MEA MAN,
DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT A SCODREL.
IS SHE'S SEEN AS A SCOUNDREL IN
CHICAGO  MOST PEOPLE
>> WELL, JESSE, FIR OFF,
MERRY CHRISTMAS, AND YES, MOST
CHICAGOANS DO N FIND -- FIN
IT VERY CH HYPOCRITICAL THAT
THE MAYOR 15 MONTHS AGO TOLD
DONALD TRUMPO GET THE HL OUT
OF CHICAGO WITH H ASSISTANCE,
AND BASICALLY PLAY POLICS WITH
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND RE WE ARE, IN 2021,VER
812 PPLE MURRED BY
GUN OLENCE IN THE CIT OF
CHICAGO.THAT NUMBER COINUES TO .
HAVE SEEN ME CHILDN
IMPACT BY GUN VIOLENCE THAN BY
COVID, AND NOW SHE IS DNG THE
GREAT PIVOT, THE GREAT
ABOUT-FACE, SAYING N THAT
PRESIDENT JOE BIN'S HERE, SHE
WI TAKE THE HELP.
WHATBOUT ALLHOSE THOUSANDS
OF PEOE WHOSE LIV HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY G VIOLENCE OR THE
LIVES THAT WERE LOST LAST YEAR
WH SHE COULD HAVE H HELP
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVNMENT?
WOT TALK ABOUT IT, WON'TPPLY
APOLIZE FORT, WISHES TO
EEP IT UNDER THE RUG.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU SAYING MORE
CHILDREN I CHICAGO HAV DIED
FROM BULLETS THAN COVID-1?
>> ME CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
VICTIMIZED BY GUN VIOLENCE IN
THEITYF CHICAGO THAT HAVE
ENTIRE STATE O ILLINOIS IN THE
LAST YEAR.>> Jesse: WOW FOR THER
STATE OF ILLINOIS, IT ISASTOUND.
>> YET WE STILL TALK ME ABOUT
COVID TH WE DO VIOLENCE.
>> Jesse: WHY NOT, IT
DISTRACTS FROMLL OF THE
BLOODSHED.
HAVE YOU HEA ANYTHING FROM
BACK OBA?
DOES HE EVER TALK ABOUT THE
SURGE IN HOMICES?
THE GUYS HOMOWN, I KNOW
LIVES ITHE VINEYAR AND
HAWA NOW,UT YOU EVER HEARHIM EMS
HOMETOWN TO DO SOMHING ABOUT
THE VIOLENCE?
>> EVEN AS PRESIDENT OMA WORKS
BUILDG HIS OBA CENR IN
WOODLAWN AND MANY OF OUR CITY
OFFICIALS E JOINING THE BIDENADE
ONE OF THE MOST RCEIVED
OLENT CITIES INMERICA SMSTO B LD
EVERY DAY RESIDENTS THRGHOUT
THE CITY OF CHICAGO ARE
STRUGGLI.
THEY FEEL THAT THEY ARE QUITE
LITERALLY UNDER THE G ANY TIME
THEY STEP OUT OF THEIR HOME,
WHETHER TOAKE THEIR KIDS TO
HOOL OR GO TO WORK, OR WHETR
IT IS JUST TTAKE A WALK AROD
THE BLOCK.
CHILDREN, WORKINGARENTS, AND
EVEN OUR SENIORS ARE AT THERIGHY
DAY IN THE CITY, WITH NO ONEWANY
FOR IT OR TO PROPOSE REAL
SOLUTIONS OTHER AN BLAMINGSOMEOM
LORI LIGHTFOOT THIS WEEK.
THEN WHAT WERE SEEING RIGHTNOW T
MANYOCRATIC POLITICIA, AND
IILL SAY IS  DEMOCRAT, I FIND
IT DISSTING THAT WE ARE AT
THIS POINT, BUT THEY PUSHED TO
THPENDULUM SO FAR TO THE LEFT
EN IT COMESO CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM THAT WE NOW FAVOR
CRIMINALS OVER VICTIMS, AND THAT
EVEN AS THE POLITICIANS ARE
BECOMING VICTIMS THEMSVES, I
AM MORE THA CERTAIN THEY WIL
NEVERCCEPT RESPONSIBILY FOR
E SEEDS THEY HAVE  TO
BRING US TO THIS POINT.
>> Jesse: [LAUGHS]
EVEN AFTER GETTING CARJACKEDT
NPOINT.
THEY ARE STI NOT GOING TO
CHGE THEIR POSITION.
IT IS UNBIEVABLE, B AT THIS
POINT, IT IS N